this is a
really
very important moment for us
it's an announcement that sent
shockwaves around the sporting world
swimming's world governing body fina
voting to ban transgender women from
female events if they've experienced any
part of male puberty
it is a policy
that we need to introduce in order to
protect the competitive fairness
of our of our events
a report from a scientific panel
concluded that male puberty gives
individuals significant physical
advantages in sport
the decision would stop american athlete
leah thomas who recently became the
first transgender swimmer to win a
college title from representing her
country at the olympics fina has said it
will now set up an open category for
athletes whose gender identity does not
match their sex at birth there must be
categories
women men and of course a category for
trans women and trans men a space
i want anyone who loves competing in
aquatic sports to have a space
and to achieve their goals
in that space
fair competition is a stronghold and
staple of our community i am asking
everyone to take a breath
listen
before reacting
listen to the science and experts
listen to the people who have stood up
here and have been telling you how
difficult it has been to reconcile
inclusion and fairness
swimming is the second olympic
discipline after rugby to introduce such
a ban most other sports use testosterone
levels as a basis for allowing trans
women to compete
i did not see this coming i have
believed for a long time that we can
talk about what the barriers to entry
look like what transition requirements
look like but outright bans
for any
trans woman who experienced part of
puberty i didn't see it coming
other sports now have to decide if with
its proposed open category swimming has
set a precedent they wish to follow andy
richardson al jazeera